alors est-ce que les beckham s'était dit
est-ce que c'est pas même feeling qu un
petit moment juste un chiffre avant de
donner la parole les bécanes donc à eux
deux fortune estimée du couple 550
millions d'euros
voilà donc est ce que vous vous qu'il
ait voulu photographier vous qu'il ait
paparazzé est-ce qu'ils sont toujours
ensemble ou pas pour donner la parole
peut-être un paparazzi vous les avez
déjà paparazzi elle et les beckham oui
il ya longtemps quand il était vraiment
ensemble
non ils sont ensemble mais enfin bon je
pense que plus le temps passe plus on
s'approche de la fin des couples comme
ça ça ça tient jamais à vie on a vu avec
brad pitt angelina jolie
là effectivement ils sont très liés au
niveau business donc le divorce serait
certainement compliqué donc j'imagine
que mes mirettes
reposez-vous qui est d'après stephen
hess que grosso modo voilà est-ce qu'ils
sont ils vivent encore ensemble oui
encore ensemble parce que ça puisqu'ils
ont chacun un amant ou une maîtresse est
toujours à couple après c'est sûr que ça
a été toujours un peu compliqué il ya eu
les affaires répliquer aux rebecca luz
en 2004 il ya eu plusieurs d'épisodes de
tromperie et à chaque fois ils s'en sont
sortis encore plus fort et pour le coup
effectivement ils sont extrêmement liés
par le business mais ils vivent toujours
ensemble
on a énormément de photos sébastien tu
le sais bien avec leur nom depuis
toujours
non mais là récemment il y en a eu un
exemple mais on a souvent des photos
d'eux en famille voilà donc non ils
vivent ensemble c'est une vraie famille
sont quand même assez uni oui dieu pas
bref c'est une famille très business
effectivement on voit qu'elle est
fragilisée vous savez à quoi
non elle fait de plus en plus de
chirurgie esthétique ça dénote une femme
qui est pas en grande confiance
elles avaient ou non n'ont toujours fait
elle ne se fait jamais sans sa marque de
7-6 en suisse c'est vrai qu'il n'a brisé
pas ça parce que j'y peux de petite
petite précision et c'est qu'elle gagne
puisque son mari elle gagne les rangs
car malgré le déficit de ça que vous
êtes allé jusque son mari elle gagne
plus que vit aujourd'hui avec un hayon
différentes millions $ par an mais nike
ou avec quoi avec ces avec ses vêtements
avec la pub ça on va me dire que le ps
peut y avoir un déficit mais peu
familier de l'argent elle gagne plus que
lui en ce moment vraiment faire et déjà
des sites on gagne de l'argent
c'était toujours d'économies par
catherine rambert
sa boîte et être en déficit d'accord
mais elle gagne avec les réseaux sociaux
et tout et tout mais que la febetra
conçoit star ou pas en fait le couple ça
reste l'intime centre de personnes et le
temps fait généralement son affaire et
heureusement ou pas peut-être que dans
ma vie les gens n'ont pas qu'un seul
amour ça se trouve ça finira mais je
pense que pour leur business
il sera bientôt derrière des vêtements
tandis qu il est dans les loges seleçao
si c'est comme ça chez lescar aussi elle
la tromperie chez les stars aussi au
bout d'un moment on se rend compte qu'on
a évolué on aime plus on n'aime plus la
personne
ça peut arriver mais pour eux je pense
que ce serait bientôt grâce de l'image
du couple
c'est la vraie vie tu veux dire dacourt
blick en privé ça se trouve ils ont
chacun leur copine et vous avez une info
pas juste ailleurs guillaume et puis luc
et ne faut pas on parle aussi du retour
des spice girls voilà et que victoria
n'en ferait pas peur et lamba parti a
priori un concert elle vend ce elles
vont se reformer et victoria prépare à
dick a dit qu'elle ne voulait pas en
faire partie maintenant concernant les
rumeurs de divorce de beckham et il
était chez des amis dans le sud-ouest
qui possède des vignes et un grand vin
rémy avon ouais et mes amis qui
connaissent les beckham à qui on les a
reçus vous êtes dans les propriétés dans
le bordelais on reçoit des gens ans a
fait partie de ces du marketing on les a
mais pas dans l'oubli et avec eva
longoria
le grand chef et mes amis m'ont dit je
les ai appelés lundi
si c'est un couple qui est au bord de la
rupture il ya trois semaines il se
bécoter c'était l'amour annie ya encore
eu 2 comment dire c'est pas une vraie
crise de couple c'est juste qu'il a
donné cet été a vu de 8 minutes et
pendant une minute ils nous demandaient
comment ça marche folle de coupe et il a
dit oui le couple c'est du travail et
c'est qu'à aucun moment il a dit j'aime
ma femme mais parce qu'il a way une
évidence pour lui et elle du coup alors
l'a mal pris parce qu'elle aurait voulu
que dans les huit minutes elle disait
marcel mateu 20 ans elle est partie
quand même deux jours deux jours en cure
de 2e mentalement je sais pas si
certains programmes je suis en couple
depuis un an il a raison c'est des
bouleaux d'être en côte d'ivoire
l'amour ça c'est pas les gens
demain catherine robert si un couple
depuis 20 ans et c'est difficile magali
sont les ventes assez d'oxygène mais moi
je trouve que c'est une belle famille
je les vois sincère trois enfants ils
ont trois peut-être enfin milieu trouve
que voilà et c'est un fantasme de dire
qui divorce à sa fin ça fait parler et
c'est cependant dans la communication
il faut savoir quand même que les
célibataires vendent plus que les coûts
parce que les couples et a plus rien à
gratter
alors qu'un célibataire qui va faire la
fête et c'est beaucoup plus vendeur donc
pas que ce soit calculé leur coupe n'est
pas calculé ça se voit la forme de ce
que je ne suis pas dans l'info ce que je
retiens tout ce que vous avez dit c'est
qu'ils sont toujours ensemble
voici une info parce que je savais pas
assisté aux deux points devant les
caméras etc ensuite quand il était enfin
n'étaient plus ensemble
donc merci beaucoup